we bandy these words around a little too
quickly these days they all kind of mean
the same thing you know authenticity and
tension you know purpose flow all these
things you know of course it matters
what is the what is the birth of this
motivation is that for PR is it is it to
entire Millennials because that's what
they want so we'll give it to them you
know is it is it because the street
demands it or is it or is it because
it's something I fundamentally believe
in I'm I'm very 4 with the round table
announced the statements a bit pablum
but you know reads like a you know the
generic values that put on the wall of a
generic company I would have liked to
have seen them the people who they
attribute the work to in the press
release to folks like Kip Tindell from
Container Store or Jim Senegal from
Costco who've been leading this way for
decades and have been outspoken about
the way business has been done and been
criticized for it for decades like
they're better messengers for it because
they're deeply they have that deep
intention they fundamentally believe
business should be done this way and the
true infinite minded player wants to
build a business not just to build a
better business for themselves it's they
want to build a business because they
want to build business better so they
don't just come up with an idea and then
hoard it they come up with Eddie and
share it because it's good for the game
it's about perpetuating the game so if
the intention is to see all ships rise
then then I'm very open to what these
these companies are saying if the
intention is to see our ship rise I've
become a little cynical
[Music]